As a young adult, finding the right path to your future can feel overwhelming.
作为一个年轻人，找到通往未来的正确道路可能会让人感到不知所措。
It starts with year up United's tuition-free job training program, Career Pathways.
它始于一年一度的美联航免学费职业培训计划“职业道路”。
If you're without a bachelor's degree but have a high school diploma or GED, you can get skills first training to succeed in the industries you're passionate about all while earning a weekly educational stipend to offset basic expenses.
如果您没有学士学位，但拥有高中文凭或 GED，您可以获得技能优先培训，以便在您热衷的行业中取得成功，同时获得每周的教育津贴来抵消基本费用。
From there, There, you'll have access to internships and hands-on experiences with Fortune 500 companies and with year-up, unites, job placement services, and personalized coaching and mentorship, you can put your knowledge, skills, and most importantly confidence into practice.
从那里，您将有机会获得财富 500 强公司的实习机会和实践经验，并通过年度提升、联合、就业安置服务以及个性化辅导和指导，您可以将您的知识、技能和最重要的信心付诸实践。
Apply to year-up united today and take the first step toward achieving the career you want.
立即申请year-up United，迈出实现您想要的职业生涯的第一步。
Visit yearup.org to learn more.
访问yearup.org 了解更多信息。
Hi, it's Paula from Italy.
嗨，我是来自意大利的宝拉。
The first time I watched Elmate Armada was during the first wave of COVID that came March of 2020.
我第一次观看 Elmate Armada 是在 2020 年 3 月爆发的第一波新冠疫情期间。
My name's Josh.
我叫乔什。
I first watched the show as a college student in New York.
我第一次看这个节目时还是纽约的一名大学生。
My name is Anna.
我叫安娜。
I am in Los Angeles, planet Earth.
我在地球洛杉矶。
How I met your mother is special because whether I've had a fantastic day or a fucking terrible day, watching that show is always the right move for the mood.
我遇见你母亲的方式很特别，因为无论我度过了美好的一天还是糟糕透顶的一天，观看那个节目总是适合心情的举动。
My friend told me to watch the show and just said, I'm Ted Mosby.
我的朋友让我看这个节目并只是说，我是特德·莫斯比。
I had no idea what he's talking about.
我不知道他在说什么。
And I watched him and I came back to him when I said, mm-hmm, can't tell mostly.
我看着他，当我说，嗯，嗯，大部分都说不出来时，我又回到了他身边。
You remember, it was hard time with strict lockdowns and isolation.
你记得，那是一段严格封锁和隔离的艰难时期。
After a very tough day, every night I watched some of my episodes to, let's say, overcome such difficult times.
在经历了非常艰难的一天之后，每天晚上我都会观看一些剧集，以克服这样的困难时期。
It feels right, regardless, to go spend time with those characters, those candid, stumbling, hilarious, raunchy, relentlessly themselves people.
不管怎样，花时间和这些角色在一起感觉是对的，那些坦率、跌跌撞撞、热闹、不修边幅、无情的他们自己。
And that gives the same feeling, the same quality of what good friendship is.
这与良好的友谊有着同样的感觉和品质。
And being between junior and senior year of college, I was terrified of what was coming next and how to make it happen the way I want.
在大学三年级和四年级之间，我对接下来发生的事情以及如何让它按照我想要的方式发生感到恐惧。
Then there was this wonderful show.
然后就有了这场精彩的表演。
That was all about how the randomness of life is what gets you exactly where you need to be.
这就是关于生活的随机性如何让你准确地到达你需要的地方。
I'm a lobby soon in New York City when I see you.
当我见到你时，我很快就到了纽约市的大厅。
Please permit me to tell you everything in New York City.
请允许我告诉你纽约市的一切。
Well, hello, hello.
嗯，你好，你好。
This is Josh Radner.
这是乔什·拉德纳。
I am here with my friend Craig Thomas.
我和我的朋友克雷格·托马斯在这里。
Hi, Josh.
嗨，乔什。
Hey, it's great to be here with you.
嘿，很高兴和你在一起。
Welcome to the first episode of How We Made Your Mother.
欢迎收看《我们如何成就了你的母亲》第一集。
Are we calling it Hwimium?
我们称之为 Hwimium 吗？
I was wondering about that.
我对此感到好奇。
Hwimium.
Hwimium。
I think it's Hwimium.
我认为是 Hwimium。
Does it work?
有效吗？
I think it does, yeah.
我想确实如此，是的。
So, how I make your mother, which is the show under discussion, is a show that ran on CBS from 2005 to 2014.
那么，我们正在讨论的节目《我如何塑造你的母亲》是哥伦比亚广播公司 (CBS) 2005 年至 2014 年播出的一档节目。
Is that right, Craig?
是这样吗，克雷格？
That is correct, nine seasons.
没错，九季。
Nine seasons.
九个季节。
So, almost a decade of our lives, I played the eye in how I made your mother.
所以，在我们生命的近十年里，我一直在扮演如何塑造你母亲的角色。
I played the character of Ted Mosby for nine seasons and Craig tell us what you did on the show.
我扮演了泰德·莫斯比这个角色九季，克雷格告诉我们你在剧中做了什么。
I was Barney.
我是巴尼。
No, that's right, I remember that.
不，是这样，我记得。
I have not aged well, if you're watching on the YouTube.
如果你在 YouTube 上观看的话，我还没有老好。
No, I'm the co-creator of the show, along with my very brilliant writing partner, Carter Bays, who will be a guest on here to discuss future and future episodes.
不，我是该剧的共同创作者，还有我非常出色的编剧搭档卡特·贝斯（Carter Bays），他将作为嘉宾来讨论未来和未来的剧集。
And we were lucky enough to create the show that found our way to the likes of you, Mr. Ratner.
拉特纳先生，我们很幸运能够制作出这样的节目，并受到了像您这样的人的喜爱。
Oh, thanks.
哦，谢谢。
Well, Craig and I have obviously been friends now for coming on two decades, which is astonishing.
嗯，克雷格和我显然已经是二十年来的朋友了，这令人惊讶。
We both now live in New York.
我们现在都住在纽约。
About once a year, I would say, we have a habit of grabbing a meal or some drinks and talk inevitably turns to how I made your mother as well as other things that are happening in our lives.
我想说，大约每年一次，我们都有吃一顿饭或喝点饮料的习惯，谈话不可避免地会转向我如何创造你的母亲以及我们生活中发生的其他事情。
But I so enjoy talking about how I made your mother with you and unpacking this thing we made that has been the biggest gift and has carried a lot of shadow with it.
但我非常喜欢谈论我如何与你一起创造你的母亲，并打开我们制作的这个东西的包装，它是最大的礼物，并带有很多阴影。
And it's just like all things is a very complicated thing, but also a very beautiful thing.
就像所有的事物都是一件非常复杂的事情，但同时也是一件非常美丽的事情一样。
And you're the person I love talking about this show with the most.
你是我最喜欢谈论这个节目的人。
So when this idea struck me like, you know what?
所以当我想到这个想法时，你知道吗？
It's actually time for me to turn around and revisit how I met your mother, but also watch it a lot of the episodes for the first time.
事实上，我是时候回过头来回顾一下我是如何认识你母亲的，而且很多情节都是第一次看。
I only watched about half the episodes, what it was on.
我只看了大约一半的剧集，内容是什么。
So I will be rewatching the show along with you and our listeners, some of whom I assume will be coming to the show for the first time.
因此，我将与您和我们的听众一起重新观看该节目，我认为其中一些人将是第一次观看该节目。
Other ones will have watched it many times and are just looking for the backstage notes here.
其他人可能已经看过很多次了，只是在这里寻找后台笔记。
But I figured if I'm going to do this, why don't we, why don't we put it on the record and actually just walk through the show together and much like the older wiser narrator Ted, which we are now around that age.
但我想，如果我要这样做，我们为什么不，为什么我们不把它记录下来，实际上只是一起走过这个节目，就像年长的、更明智的叙述者泰德一样，我们现在大约在那个年龄。
Let's look back and see who we were, who we are now, where we're going.
让我们回顾一下，看看我们曾经是谁，现在是谁，我们要去哪里。
And yeah, what else would you say about what we're doing here?
是的，对于我们在这里所做的事情，您还有什么想说的吗？
Well, first of all, I can't believe you only watched half of the episodes.
好吧，首先，我不敢相信你只看了一半的剧集。
I'm deeply offended.
我深感被冒犯。
I think I'm just going to walk off.
我想我要走开。
I'm walking off the project.
我要离开这个项目了。
No, the truth is, I haven't rewatched the show door-to-door since it went off.
不，事实是，自从节目播出以来，我还没有挨家挨户地重看过。
I've seen episodes, but I haven't watched a door-to-door.
我看过几集，但没看过挨家挨户的。
And so I think what we're doing here is excavating back into our past.
所以我认为我们在这里所做的就是挖掘我们的过去。
It was almost a decade of our lives.
这几乎是我们生命中的十年。
And we're trying to figure out what did we do there?
我们试图弄清楚我们在那里做了什么？
What happened?
发生了什么？
We made this thing.
我们做了这个东西。
It's like the pineapple episode.
这就像菠萝情节。
You're like, what?
你就像，什么？
We have to piece it together.
我们必须把它拼凑起来。
We're doing the pineapple incident, but for the entire series, what happened?
我们正在做菠萝事件，但是对于整个系列来说，发生了什么？
We woke up, we woke up, we're we've awakened and we're almost 50 or I think you're a bureaucrat there and I'm almost there.
我们醒了，我们醒了，我们已经醒了，我们已经快50岁了，或者我认为你是那里的官僚，而我也快到了。
And we're kind of going, wait, we are closer to the age of future Ted.
我们正在走，等等，我们离未来特德的时代更近了。
We are closer to 2030 and then we were to do that, we are to 2005 when the show launched.
我们已经接近 2030 年，然后我们就可以做到这一点，我们已经到了 2005 年该节目推出的时候。
And it is just it is strange.
只是很奇怪。
I was thinking about the sort of symmetry of it.
我在思考它的对称性。
We are something like I think 20 years since the premiere, I think this September will be 20 years since the premiere.
我们就像是首映二十周年，我想今年九月首映二十周年了。
We are just past 10 years of it, of the finale airing, of it finishing airing.
我们已经过去十年了，它的结局播出，它的结束播出。
So there's a lot of round numbers, there's a 20 and there's a 10 and here we are.
所以有很多整数，有 20，有 10，我们在这里。
And it just seems like a good moment to kind of look back and take stock of it.
这似乎是回顾和评估它的好时机。
Yeah.
是的。
I, another thing that I, when I called you to talk about this that I really wanted to talk about, I said, I am a astonished one at the kind of long tail of the show.
我，另一件事，当我打电话给你谈论这个我真正想谈论的事情时，我说，我对这部剧的长尾感到惊讶。
You know, a lot of shows go off the air and, and they go off the air, they go away, you know, and maybe they come up randomly in a, I don't know, trivia night or, you know, remember that, a moment will come back to you.
你知道，很多节目都停播了，然后它们停播了，它们就消失了，你知道，也许它们会在一个我不知道的琐事之夜中随机出现，或者，你知道，记住这一点，一会儿你就会回想起。
But there's something about how I made my mother one, it keeps minting new fans, so people that were babies, children, or even in their teens when it was on have now discovered it.
但我是如何让我的母亲成为这样的人的，它不断地吸引着新的粉丝，所以当它播出时，婴儿、儿童甚至十几岁的人现在都发现了它。
I also think there's a really sweet thing.
我也觉得有一个非常甜蜜的事情。
I think parents are showing it to their teenage kids now.
我认为父母现在正在向十几岁的孩子展示它。
They're like, this show taught me a lot about, you know, being an adult or a young adult navigating all these things.
他们就像，这个节目教会了我很多关于，你知道，作为一个成年人或一个年轻人如何应对所有这些事情。
But also, I'm astonished at a number of things.
但同时，我对很多事情感到惊讶。
But one of the ones that strikes me about when I hear from how I made my mother fan, something I hear so consistently that it's not just anecdotal.
但当我听到我如何让我母亲成为粉丝时，令我印象深刻的是，我经常听到这样的事情，这不仅仅是轶事。
There has to be something there, which is that people say, I got turned on to the show or I started watching the show when I was in a really hard moment of my life, whether it's, you know, it's going through a divorce or a sickness or my parent had died.
那里一定有一些东西，那就是人们说，我开始看这个节目，或者当我处于人生中非常困难的时刻时，我开始看这个节目，无论是，你知道，正在经历离婚、生病还是我的父母去世。
I was having a personal kind of moment of crisis.
我正经历着个人的危机时刻。
And there seems to be that this thing I've noticed that how I met your mother is like soul medicine for people going through hard times.
我注意到，我是如何认识你母亲的，这件事似乎对于经历困难时期的人来说就像是灵魂良药。
And I don't know that it was conceived of that exactly.
我不知道它是否是这样构想的。
I don't think you and Carter sat out in 2004 and said, I know what we'll do.
我不认为你和卡特在 2004 年袖手旁观并说，我知道我们会做什么。
We'll do a sole panacea for people.
我们将为人们做唯一的灵丹妙药。
But it seems like that's what it does for people.
但这似乎就是它对人们的作用。
And I hear it so consistently that it strikes me as something worth exploring.
我经常听到它，这让我觉得它是值得探索的东西。
It's such an honor.
真是太荣幸了。
People come up to us all the time and to you Josh and say the show got them through something really hard.
人们总是来找我们和乔什，说这部剧帮助他们度过了非常艰难的时期。
And getting that, or they say, I married my wife because we realized we're both how much mother fans.
明白了这一点，或者他们说，我嫁给了我的妻子，因为我们意识到我们都是妈妈的粉丝。
So they met in an event or something.
所以他们是在一次活动或者什么事情上认识的。
It's just just the ways the show has been crucial in people's lives, like the opening words from the fans.
这只是这部剧对人们生活至关重要的方式，就像粉丝们的开场白一样。
We have the greatest fans of any fans.
我们拥有所有粉丝中最伟大的粉丝。
How much more the fans are so amazing.
何况粉丝们还这么厉害。
Huge shout out to the fans.
向粉丝们大声喊叫。
If you were listening to this, you were an amazing person.
如果你听到这个，你就是一个了不起的人。
And I find such an openness, Josh, to come talk to us about stuff.
乔什，我发现自己很愿意来和我们谈论一些事情。
Do you get this a little bit?
你明白一点了吗？
Cause I'm a writer and people I have to go around telling people I wear a little shirt that says I create a how much mother and just you got that needy.
因为我是一名作家，我必须到处告诉人们我穿着一件小衬衫，上面写着我创造了一个多少母亲，而你有那么需要。
I wear it on my face, I have a tattooed on my face.
我把它戴在脸上，我的脸上有纹身。
You have tattooed on your face.
你的脸上有纹身。
And I've been dying for years to ask you the sort of two-part question.
多年来我一直渴望问你这种由两部分组成的问题。
What was it like being Ted when the show was on and blowing up and not being able to escape Ted's face, your face is Ted's face, although you are not Ted.
当节目播出时，作为 Ted 的感觉如何，火爆了，无法逃脱 Ted 的脸，你的脸就是 Ted 的脸，尽管你不是 Ted。
And then what has that felt like kind of in the long 10 years since it went off the air, what is it, what has that felt like?
那么自从它停播以来的漫长十年里，这感觉是什么样的，那是什么，那感觉是什么样的？
The reason I thought of that is that you just said people come up to you and they share these things with you.
我这么想的原因是你刚才说人们来找你并与你分享这些事情。
That seems like a real gift.
这看起来像是一份真正的礼物。
But I'm sure there's also like, enormous, weird downside.
但我确信还有一个巨大的、奇怪的缺点。
It's like, do a deal as it's such an interesting thing.
就像，做一笔交易，因为这是一件很有趣的事情。
Let's do a little time or episode on being Ted Mosby.
让我们用一段时间或一段时间来讲述一下特德·莫斯比的故事。
I think there's a lot to unpack that I wouldn't be able to unpack here.
我认为有很多东西需要解开，但我在这里无法解开。
But I'll do a little bit of it.
但我会做一点点。
I will say this.
我会这么说。
I remember I was writing Liberal Arts for the second film I wrote and directed.
我记得我正在为我自编自导的第二部电影撰写文科课程。
And it was 2009 or 10.
那是2009年或10年。
I think it was 2010.
我认为那是2010年。
And I went to Spain for a month, kicked around Spain, went to about five or six cities, wrote during the day and kind of just got into trouble at night on some level.
我去了西班牙一个月，在西班牙各地闲逛，去了大约五六个城市，白天写作，晚上在某种程度上遇到了麻烦。
I mean, it was just really fun.
我的意思是，这真的很有趣。
And my friend, Horula, introduced me to all her friends who were living in Spain.
我的朋友霍鲁拉把我介绍给她所有住在西班牙的朋友。
So I had like these blind friend dates everywhere I went.
所以我到处都有这样的盲目朋友约会。
But I would leave my hotel or wherever I was staying.
但我会离开我的酒店或我住的地方。
And I would, people, I was just getting recognized in Spain.
我会的，朋友们，我刚刚在西班牙得到认可。
And people would want a picture they want to say, hi.
人们想要一张他们想说的照片，嗨。
Well, then they'd say, do you want to come a flamenco show in a couple hours.
好吧，然后他们会说，你想在几个小时后观看弗拉门戈表演吗？
And I'd say yes.
我会说是的。
And it was like, my face was this like social.
就像，我的脸就像社交一样。
I don't know, like the fact that they were familiar with me gave them permission.
我不知道，就像他们与我熟悉的事实给了他们许可一样。
It like, it was just this weird social looper kid that I was accepted everywhere.
就好像，我就是这个奇怪的社交循环小子，到处都被接受了。
One of the things I really loved about it made the world feel much smaller.
我真正喜欢它的一件事是让世界感觉小了很多。
Right.
正确的。
You know, I've always wanted to, I don't want to talk to every person I meet, but I do like the feeling that the world is not so big and filled with anonymous scary people.
你知道，我一直想，我不想和我遇到的每个人交谈，但我确实喜欢这种感觉：世界并不是那么大，也没有充满匿名的可怕的人。
Because I find people are, most people are quite lovely once you get to know them, once you get over that kind of like your strange endeavor.
因为我发现人们是这样的，一旦你了解他们，一旦你克服了那种奇怪的努力，大多数人都是相当可爱的。
I don't know who you are, where you're from.
我不知道你是谁，来自哪里。
So it gave me like a common language with people.
所以它给了我与人们的共同语言。
I think I've told you this, but in Spain, I went to this little town called Daya, and I got really sick.
我想我已经告诉过你了，但是在西班牙，我去了一个叫达亚的小镇，我病得很厉害。
I got food poisoning for the first 24 hours.
我在最初 24 小时内食物中毒。
And I crawled out of the place I was staying and I had a hooded sweatshirt on that I think was like tied.
我爬出了我住的地方，穿着一件连帽运动衫，我认为它像是系着的。
And I was just trying to get like some ginger ale or something and some crackers because I was so I was such a mess.
我只是想喝点姜汁汽水之类的东西和一些饼干，因为我太乱了。
And there were like 10 or 12 like young college students.
大概有十到十二个年轻的大学生。
They were hotel management interns from like all over the world.
他们是来自世界各地的酒店管理实习生。
And they recognized me like through my hoodie with this sickness.
他们通过我的连帽衫认出了我，因为我得了这种病。
And they were like, Because that's head moseby vomiting in a bush.
他们就像，因为那是莫斯比在灌木丛中呕吐的头。
Yeah, exactly.
是的，完全正确。
And they invited me the next night to either come to launch your dinner, I forget.
第二天晚上他们邀请我来为你准备晚餐，我忘了。
But I ended up hanging out with these hotel management interns for like three or four days.
但我最终还是和这些酒店管理实习生一起待了三四天。
And they were incredible.
他们太不可思议了。
But this one guy owned the bar in, we were in Mallorca.
但这个人拥有酒吧，我们在马略卡岛。
And he owned the bar to be clear not the bar, not the bar that gave you food poisoning.
而且他拥有这家酒吧，要明确的是，不是酒吧，不是让你食物中毒的酒吧。
No, no, no, I wasn't.
不，不，不，我不是。
I got food poisoning in another town.
我在另一个城镇食物中毒了。
He was 23 years old.
那年他23岁。
His dad had just died.
他的父亲刚刚去世。
And so we inherited this bar.
所以我们继承了这个酒吧。
he had never been off the island of Mallorca.
他从未离开过马略卡岛。
One night he hands me a drink and he says, no can do's filled baby doll.
一天晚上，他递给我一杯饮料，他说，没有什么可以做的填充娃娃。
And he knew every single line of how I met your mother.
他知道我如何认识你母亲的每一句话。
That's so amazing.
太神奇了。
And the thing he told me that I thought was so spectacular was he said, how I met your mother has taught me that what's happening now will be my memories one day.
他告诉我的那件事让我觉得非常壮观，他说，我是如何认识你母亲的，这告诉我，现在发生的事情有一天会成为我的回忆。
right.
正确的。
So make sure that the present moment is great that you're making good memories for yourself in the present moment, you know.
因此，请确保当下时刻是美好的，以便你在当下时刻为自己创造美好的回忆，你知道。
And then these hotel management interns for some reason, like, you know, they would they would have a few drinks in them, but they would tell me like their deepest darkest secrets, like some shocking stuff.
然后这些酒店管理实习生出于某种原因，比如，你知道，他们会喝一些饮料，但他们会告诉我他们最深最黑暗的秘密，比如一些令人震惊的事情。
Yeah.
是的。
And I think there was something about they knew me.
我认为他们有些了解我。
They felt like you knew.
他们感觉就像你知道一样。
They felt comfortable with it.
他们对此感到很舒服。
Yeah, that's it.
是的，就是这样。
This is not an invitation, by the way, if you're hearing this to come up to me and tell me about your drama.
顺便说一句，如果你听到这个消息是为了向我讲述你的戏剧，那么这并不是一个邀请。
Tell you really weird.
告诉你真的很奇怪。
So let's beat your dishes.
所以让我们来打败你的菜吧。
Let's have boundaries.
让我们有界限。
But there is something about this.
但这是有道理的。
This is the kind of stuff I really love is, it gave me like access to people in a way that made the world feel friendly.
这是我真正喜欢的东西，它让我能够以一种让世界感到友好的方式接触人们。
That's a beautiful story.
这是一个美丽的故事。
That is a key.
那是一把钥匙。
You have like the skeleton key to let you into doors and would not have been open.
你就像一把万能钥匙，可以让你进门却打不开。
and I wrote you this little ditty to sing to you in New York City.
我写了这首小曲给你在纽约唱给你听。
We'll be here right back.
我们马上回来。
You know, there was a time when I would ignore, or maybe not even notice, when my sheets started slipping off the corners, or peeling, or when my pillows weren't quite as supportive as I wanted them to be.
你知道，曾经有一段时间，当我的床单开始从角落滑落或剥落，或者当我的枕头没有像我希望的那样支撑时，我会忽略，或者甚至没有注意到。
My wife, however, has always noticed this sort of thing.
然而，我的妻子总是注意到这种事情。
But now that we got a baby, waking up at, you know, various times, every moment of sleep has become invaluable.
但现在我们有了孩子，在不同的时间醒来，每一刻的睡眠都变得非常宝贵。
And I am so delighted that Bull and Branch sent us some of the comefiest sheets that I have ever had the pleasure to sleep upon.
我很高兴布尔和布兰奇给我们送来了一些最舒适的床单，我曾经很高兴睡在上面。
Their organic cotton bedding is designed for deep uninterrupted rest, which is what we're getting.
他们的有机棉床上用品专为深度不间断的休息而设计，这正是我们所得到的。
The sheets are incredibly soft.
床单非常柔软。
They're breathable and it's a total game changer for our energy levels, especially with this young, occasionally sleeping baby we have now.
它们透气，完全改变了我们的能量水平，尤其是对于我们现在这个偶尔睡觉的小婴儿来说。
This is the kind of comfort we can't afford to compromise anymore.
这是我们不能再妥协的舒适感。
Upgrade your sleep with Bowling Branch.
Bowling Branch 提升您的睡眠质量。
Get 15% off your first order plus free shipping at BowlingBranch.com.
在 BowlingBranch.com 首次订购可享受 15% 折扣，并免运费。
Slash your mother with code, your mother.
用代码砍你妈，你妈。
That's Bowling Branch, B-O-L-L-A-N-D branch dot com slash your mother code your mother to unlock 15% off exclusions apply.
那是保龄球分店，B-O-L-L-A-N-D 分店 . com 削减你的母亲代码你的母亲解锁 15% 折扣排除适用。
Hey, I'm Carl Radke.
嘿，我是卡尔·拉德克。
You might know me from Bravo Summer House, but on my podcast More Life, I get your favorite reality stars off the clock and into the conversations you don't usually get to hear, the deep stuff, the vulnerable stuff, the uncomfortable stuff.
你可能在 Bravo Summer House 认识我，但在我的播客 More Life 中，我会不分昼夜地让你最喜欢的真人秀明星进入你通常听不到的对话，深刻的东西，脆弱的东西，不舒服的东西。
I've sat down with Sierra Miller, Durinda Medley, Tom Schwartz, Lindsay Hubbard, and a whole lot more.
我与塞拉·米勒 (Sierra Miller)、杜林达·梅德利 (Durinda Medley)、汤姆·施瓦茨 (Tom Schwartz)、林赛·哈伯德 (Lindsay Hubbard) 等人进行了交谈。
We get into relationships, growing up, the messy stuff, and everything that happens when the cameras aren't rolling.
我们会陷入人际关系、成长、混乱的事情，以及摄像机不转动时发生的一切。
New episodes of More Life every week, listen wherever you get your podcasts or watch on YouTube.
More Life 每周都有新剧集，无论您在哪里收听播客或在 YouTube 上观看。
Josh.
乔什。
Yeah, Alec.
是的，亚历克。
You have a new baby, a new child.
你有一个新的婴儿，一个新的孩子。
He's not so new.
他并不是那么新。
Nine months?
九个月？
Is that new?
那是新的吗？
That's not that new, actually, so how have you started keeping track of his spending?
实际上，这并不是什么新鲜事，那么你是如何开始跟踪他的支出的呢？
What we're spending on him or what he personally is spending?
我们在他身上花了什么，或者他个人在花什么？
what he personally is charging at the at the at the local convenience shop at the at the five and dime.
他个人在当地便利店的收费是五毛钱。
Yeah, we we decided it's not safe to give him money because he would like he does with everything else we had he would eat it.
是的，我们认为给他钱是不安全的，因为他希望他能把我们拥有的其他东西都吃掉。
He didn't put it in his mouth and you know, money and coins it's not it's not what you want your baby eating.
他没有把它放进嘴里，你知道，钱和硬币不是你想让你的宝宝吃的东西。
So we're we're keeping them off the money train for just a bit longer, but I imagine you have teenagers, right?
所以我们要让他们远离金钱列车一段时间，但我想你有青少年，对吧？
So you're you're are probably in the thick of the money game with them, right?
所以你可能正与他们陷入激烈的金钱游戏，对吧？
I absolutely am.
我绝对是。
And now that their money basically exists in the netherworld of telephone version, there's no cash, right?
而现在他们的钱基本上都存在于电话版的幽冥界，没有现金吧？
Used to be, you give your kid cash to the rundown to the chocolate shop, pick up an egg cream.
过去，你给孩子现金去巧克力店，买一个鸡蛋奶油。
Yeah, you have no idea what this money's being spent on, but there's a solution for that.
是的，你不知道这些钱花在了什么地方，但有一个解决方案。
What's that?
那是什么？
Well, for all the parents out there with teenagers, we know you're already trying to keep a million different things under control.
好吧，对于所有有青少年的父母来说，我们知道你们已经在努力控制一百万种不同的事情。
Cash app is here to help make sure your teen's money and their spending is in adding to that craziness.
现金应用程序可以帮助确保您的孩子有钱，而他们的支出会加剧这种疯狂。
By sponsoring your teen age 13 to 17, they can get a custom Cash app card set personal savings goals and even earn interest on savings with zero monthly fees.
通过赞助 13 至 17 岁的青少年，他们可以获得定制的现金应用卡，设定个人储蓄目标，甚至可以以零月费赚取储蓄利息。
No minimum balance and complete oversight from your account.
无最低余额限制，并由您的账户进行全面监督。
New cash app customers can earn $10 if they use code Family10 in their profile at signup and send $5 to a friend within 14 days.
新的现金应用程序客户如果在注册时使用个人资料中的代码 Family10 并在 14 天内向朋友发送 5 美元，即可赚取 10 美元。
Terms apply.
条款适用。
Cash app is a financial services platform, not a bank.
现金应用程序是一个金融服务平台，而不是银行。
Banking service is provided by Cash app's bank partners.
银行服务由 Cash app 的银行合作伙伴提供。
Prepaid debit cards issued by Sutton bank, member FDIC, cash app visa, debit flex cards issued by Sutton bank, member FDIC, and the bank core bank.
Sutton 银行、FDIC 成员发行的预付借记卡、Cash App Visa、Sutton 银行、FDIC 成员和银行核心银行发行的灵活借记卡。
NA, pursuant to a license from Visa USA Incorporated.
NA，根据 Visa USA Incorporated 的许可。
Sea Terms and Conditions for the Sutton Prepaid Card, Sutton Debit Flex Card, and Bankor Debit Flex Card.
Sutton 预付卡、Sutton 借记灵活卡和 Bankor 借记灵活卡的 Sea 条款和条件。
Savings provided by CashApp, a block-incorporated brand.
由 Block-incorporated 品牌 CashApp 提供的节省。
Visit cash.app-legal-slash-podcast for full disclosures.
请访问 cash.app-legal-slash-podcast 了解完整披露信息。
And now, back's the show.
现在，节目又回来了。
It Ted is a complicated character.
泰德是一个复杂的角色。
He's a complicated character to have played because he's the eyes and ears.
他是一个复杂的角色，因为他是眼睛和耳朵。
He's the center of the show.
他是整场演出的中心人物。
He's the person that kind of welcomes the audience in.
他是那种欢迎观众进来的人。
But he was also his own really flawed, dimensional character.
但他也是他自己真正有缺陷的、立体的性格。
And I have found the people who relate to Ted are unbelievably fascinating to me.
我发现与特德有联系的人对我来说令人难以置信的着迷。
Just as many women come up to me and say, I'm like Ted as men.
正如许多女性走过来对我说，作为男人，我就像特德一样。
Oh, I love that.
哦，我喜欢那个。
Which is really incredible.
这真是令人难以置信。
Yeah.
是的。
But just like people who are worried they feel a little too much.
但就像担心的人一样，他们感觉有点太多了。
You know, Ted was probably a HSP is that a highly sensitive person.
要知道，Ted 可能是一个 HSP，是一个高度敏感的人。
I think that's fair to say.
我认为这样说是公平的。
You know, and he just had a big heart and it sometimes got in the way of social, you know, what was expected of him.
你知道，他只是有一颗宽广的心，有时这会妨碍社交，你知道，人们对他的期望。
But I just, you know, it's an honor to have played someone that kind of raw, right?
但我只是，你知道，能扮演那种原始的人是我的荣幸，对吧？
Whose nerve endings were so exposed.
谁的神经末梢如此暴露。
And it helped me, you know, it helped me become more vulnerable.
它帮助了我，你知道，它帮助我变得更加脆弱。
Disclose parts of myself that maybe I was embarrassed about that you guys were demanding that they be front and center.
透露一下我自己的部分，也许我对你们要求他们站在前面和中心感到尴尬。
And to also be even at that time, 2005 to be a publicly vulnerable male.
甚至在2005年的那个时候，也是一个公开的弱势男性。
It's still caring risks.
仍需关注风险。
How about now too?
现在也怎么样？
I mean, it carries risks.
我的意思是，它带有风险。
But it was like a big grave thing you guys asked of me and I'm grateful and I'm glad that it resonates with people and continues to.
但这就像你们向我提出的一件大事，我很感激，我很高兴它能引起人们的共鸣，并继续下去。
And it's funny what you said about being vulnerable because it was vulnerable to right too.
你所说的脆弱性很有趣，因为它也容易受到权利的影响。
Carder and I are these like super emo, like sort of we are highly sensitive people.
卡德和我都是超级情绪化的人，就像我们是高度敏感的人一样。
We wear our hearts on our sleeves.
我们把我们的心挂在袖子上。
We have big dreams like Ted.
我们像特德一样有远大的梦想。
The creation of the show, when we were 30 years old, that was a far-fetched impossible dream to create the show.
节目的创作，在我们30岁的时候，创作节目那是一个遥不可及的不可能的梦想。
that was us Ted Moes being all over the place, coming up with some big, far-fetched plan that should never have worked out at rain.
那是我们特德·莫斯到处乱跑，想出了一些宏大的、牵强的计划，而这些计划在雨天根本不应该实现。
But somehow it did demanding that it rain and somehow it worked out of not in all the ways we thought it would, which is the same story for Ted.
但不知何故，它确实要求下雨，而且不知何故，结果并不像我们想象的那样，这对特德来说也是同样的故事。
It never goes exactly how you plan, but it becomes beautiful in some different way than you ever could have imagined that was the show.
它永远不会完全按照你的计划进行，但它会以某种不同于你想象的方式变得美丽。
What's funny is, Cardinier very much liked that Marshall's a really sweet, emotional, open-hearted warm softy of a guy.
有趣的是，卡迪尼尔非常喜欢马歇尔，他是一个非常可爱、情绪化、心胸开阔、温暖而温柔的人。
He's basically had one, you know, girlfriend became this wife, and we would get these notes early on sometimes from well-meaning executives.
他基本上有一个，你知道，女朋友变成了这位妻子，有时我们会很早就从善意的高管那里得到这些笔记。
Early, and before the show was launched, probably before we even cast it, but also maybe early in the run, where we get these notes, the characters were so based on us at first, right?
早期，在节目推出之前，可能在我们选角之前，但也可能在运行的早期，我们得到这些笔记，角色一开始就是以我们为基础的，对吧？
And then it became like creating it with you guys.
然后就变成了和你们一起创造它。
But at first, it really was us.
但一开始，确实是我们。
And we would get these notes from executives.
我们会从高管那里得到这些笔记。
It would be the effect of like, these guys are just such fucking whims.
这会产生这样的效果，这些家伙就是这么他妈的突发奇想。
That's how it felt.
就是这样的感觉。
It was just like, we would get notes that to the effect of like, no man would ever, no man would call himself a man.
就像，我们会收到这样的注释，大意是，没有人会，没有人会称自己为男人。
Self-respecting man would ever behave in this way.
有自尊心的人永远都会这样做。
We're like, um, well, that's based on something that I did.
我们就像，嗯，嗯，这是基于我所做的事情。
And it was really, really weird.
这真的非常非常奇怪。
And I think it was my little glimpse at probably how it felt to you in literally your body, embodying the character, and you had to sort of carry that.
我认为这可能是我对你身体的感受的一点小小的瞥见，体现了这个角色，你必须带着它。
The MTV show Jackass, you were doing that with your heart on CBS every Monday night.
MTV 节目《Jackass》，每周一晚上你都会在 CBS 上用心做这件事。
You were just like, what happens if we push Ted's heart off a cliff in a shopping cart?
你就像，如果我们用购物车把特德的心推下悬崖，会发生什么？
Let's see what happens.
让我们看看会发生什么。
And it's just like there was kind of a stunt and emotional stuntman quality to that, and you were kind of doing your own stunts.
这就像有一种特技和情感特技演员的品质，而你是在做你自己的特技。
Yeah, especially when there's so much confusion between, you know, you know, you play a character and especially if it's the first introduction to you, you know, I didn't have a lot of public things, but I mean, I had pilots in series that didn't go anywhere and so this was where people kind of met me.
是的，尤其是当你扮演一个角色之间存在如此多的混乱，特别是如果这是第一次向你介绍时，你知道，我没有太多公开的东西，但我的意思是，我有一系列的试播集，但没有去任何地方，所以这就是人们认识我的地方。
So they thought, well, this is who this is, you know, I do remember at the beginning of I think second or third season, but I don't remember which one, but no, no, it's the beginning of third season.
所以他们想，好吧，这就是这个人，你知道，我确实记得在第二季或第三季的开头，但我不记得是哪一个，但不，不，这是第三季的开头。
And you guys wanted to really send Ted and Barney out on a lot of adventures.
你们确实想让泰德和巴尼出去进行很多冒险。
And you started writing Ted as a little more Barney-ish in terms of like he was open to like one night stands and all this stuff.
你开始把泰德写得有点像巴尼式的，因为他对一夜情和所有这些东西都持开放态度。
And I remember Pam told me that you guys got a note that said, you know, there's a lot of Barney's on TV, but there's only one Ted.
我记得帕姆告诉我，你们收到一张纸条，上面写着，电视上有很多巴尼的角色，但只有一个特德。
Let's let's keep him.
我们就留着他吧。
Let's preserve his Tedness or his Mosby-ness.
让我们保留他的泰德风格或莫斯比风格。
Yeah, totally.
是的，完全可以。
And we had a lot of really smart, strong female voices from this video and the network who really got the emotion behind the show and we're kind of guardians of that.
我们从这个视频和网络中得到了很多非常聪明、强有力的女性声音，她们真正理解了节目背后的情感，我们是它的守护者。
And that doesn't always happen.
但这并不总是发生。
And that was really nice.
那真是太好了。
And it's not like that fit in with every other show on the network at the time.
这并不适合当时网络上的所有其他节目。
And that was preserved.
那被保留下来了。
And it was what was beautiful about the show.
这就是这场演出的美妙之处。
And thank God.
感谢上帝。
I wanted to do a quick little pause and just say, our producer, Alec Lev, our wonderful and heroic producer without whom we wouldn't be doing this show.
我想稍微停顿一下，然后说，我们的制片人，亚历克·列夫，我们出色而英勇的制片人，没有他我们就不会做这个节目。
Well, chime in from time to time with a question or guidance.
好吧，时不时地提出问题或指导。
Thank you guys for, for bringing me into this.
谢谢你们，让我参与其中。
And I'm excited to be on the journey with you.
我很高兴能与您一起踏上旅程。
And yeah, you might hear some questions from me.
是的，你可能会听到我的一些问题。
My first one here if I could just throw one in Josh's wine now.
我的第一个在这里，如果我现在可以在乔希的酒里扔一个的话。
I know you've had 10 years podcasts have been around.
我知道播客已经存在 10 年了。
You've been thinking about this show and then all of a sudden Craig got the call and then I got the call.
你一直在考虑这个节目，然后突然克雷格接到了电话，然后我也接到了电话。
You'd like to think about about this now.
你现在想考虑一下这个问题。
And I'm wondering what you're talking about.
我想知道你在说什么。
But this answer will include your lovely new wife, because I'm eager to talk about that spark of it all too.
但这个答案将包括你可爱的新妻子，因为我也很想谈论这一切的火花。
Yeah, well, I did get married a year ago, almost exactly a year ago.
是的，嗯，我确实在一年前结婚了，几乎整整一年前。
Congrats.
恭喜。
And you know, I got married at 49.
你知道，我 49 岁就结婚了。
I mean, I, it took me a while to both meet my wife and to almost be ready to get married.
我的意思是，我花了一段时间才见到我的妻子并几乎准备好结婚。
And I had, without going too much into it, I had challenges in relationships.
我在人际关系方面也遇到了挑战，尽管没有过多考虑。
They were never, I found them easy to get into.
他们从来都不是，我发现他们很容易进入。
I found them hard to sustain.
我发现它们很难维持。
Let's just say that.
就这么说吧。
And a lot of that's between me and my therapist, but the journey of kind of becoming the man I, who could stand in front of my wife and make that kind of commitment was quite a journey.
其中很多是我和我的治疗师之间的事情，但是成为一个可以站在我妻子面前并做出这种承诺的男人的旅程是一段相当长的旅程。
And I felt, you know, and it was different.
我感觉，你知道，这是不同的。
Like I said, like my challenges and relationships were different.
就像我说的，我的挑战和人际关系是不同的。
Like I used to joke with people that say, you know, Ted has to be careful not to get married on the first date, but I had to be careful not to get divorced on the first date.
就像我以前和人们开玩笑说，你知道，特德必须小心不要在第一次约会时结婚，但我必须小心不要在第一次约会时离婚。
I was always like looking for the problem kind of thing, not like falling in love so quickly.
我总是喜欢寻找问题之类的事情，而不喜欢那么快坠入爱河。
But I think there's something about turning 50, having gotten married and just done some work around some of the shadowy aspects of playing Ted being thought of as a person that you're not, you know, some of that was really hard for me.
但我认为 50 岁了，结婚了，刚刚做了一些工作，解决了扮演 Ted 时被认为是一个你不是的人的一些阴暗方面，你知道，其中一些对我来说真的很难。
It was really hard to navigate just in the realm of like identity.
仅仅在相似的身份领域中导航真的很困难。
Like who am I?
比如我是谁？
Who do I self conceive of?
我自己设想的是谁？
Who do I think I am versus like all these people are telling me, you know, that's not your name, your name is not Josh, you have to be rolling around New York City with Ted and Varity and you are, but March of the Barney and you are, you know, and it felt like this almost theft of my sense of self, like it was really a challenge.
我认为我是谁，就像所有这些人告诉我的那样，你知道，那不是你的名字，你的名字不是乔什，你必须和泰德和瓦瑞蒂一起在纽约市转悠，而你是，但巴尼的三月和你是，你知道，这感觉就像是我的自我意识几乎被偷走了，就像这真的是一个挑战。
But as the years have gone by, the people who say, I had a guy from Turkey yesterday, two days ago, stopped me, came running out of coffee shop to stop me.
但随着时间的流逝，人们说，昨天，两天前，我有一个来自土耳其的人阻止了我，从咖啡店跑出来阻止我。
And he said, um, thank you so much for teaching us to believe in love, to believe in ourselves.
他说，嗯，非常感谢你教会我们相信爱，相信我们自己。
That's an amazing thing to hear on like a right morning, right?
听到这样的消息真是太棒了，就像一个正确的早晨，对吧？
11 on the morning.
上午11点。
Yeah.
是的。
And Jordan, my wife is really good at making me kind of pinch myself in those moments when she's with me, like to say like, do you see that you You were a part of something that really moved people.
乔丹，我的妻子真的很擅长让我在她和我在一起的那些时刻掐自己，比如，你看到了吗？你是真正感动人们的事情的一部分。
So the people who, it's outweighed by, you know, any of that shadowy stuff is outweighed by the people who just say like, you know, like Rob Delaney in his book, saying, my wife and I needed to laugh and we watched how I met your mother when our son was sick in the hospital.
所以，那些被那些阴暗的东西所压倒的人，被那些只是说，你知道，就像罗布·德莱尼在他的书中说的那样的人所压倒，他说，我和我的妻子需要笑，当我们的儿子生病住院时，我们看着我是如何见到你母亲的。
Like, things like that, it's made me, almost in like a, like a Jungian way, like to say, All right, there's part of Ted that is, I wrote pretty extensively about this in my newsletter, but maybe a year or two ago, but about Ted's a part of me.
就像这样的事情，它让我，几乎以一种荣格的方式，想说，好吧，这是泰德的一部分，也就是说，我在时事通讯中写了相当多的内容，但也许是一两年前，但关于泰德是我的一部分。
He's literally a part I played, but he's not all of me.
他确实是我扮演的一个角色，但他并不是我的全部。
Yeah, and I think for a long time, I was like trying to be like, that's not me, that's not me.
是的，我想很长一段时间以来，我都在努力表现出，那不是我，那不是我。
Like I was in rejection of him and I would not take roles that evoked him and I was really fighting him.
就像我在拒绝他一样，我不会扮演那些能唤起他的角色，我真的是在与他作斗争。
And I think there's something about the time in my life right now maybe it's just literally the mercy of time that has allowed me to say, all right, you know, let's turn around and look at this guy.
我认为现在我生命中的这段时间也许只是时间的仁慈让我能够说，好吧，你知道，让我们转身看看这个家伙。
Let's look at this character you played.
我们来看看你扮演的这个角色。
Let's look at who you were when you played this character.
让我们看看你扮演这个角色时是谁。
And look, I was a different person in 2005 than I was in 2014.
你看，2005 年的我和 2014 年的我是一个不同的人。
And so are you a big time, you know, a lot, change.
你知道，你也经历了很多变化。
And I'm a lot different now than I was in 2014.
现在的我与 2014 年相比有很大不同。
Yeah.
是的。
So I think it was just, you know, there's something allowed me the space and the grace and the patience with myself to go, let's stop running away.
所以我认为这只是，你知道，有某种东西给了我空间、优雅和对自己的耐心，让我们停止逃跑。
Let's actually, this is going to be in my obituary.
事实上，这将出现在我的讣告中。
A lot of people recognize me from it and still want to talk about it.
很多人从中认出了我，并且仍然想谈论它。
So I just, I wanted to drop whatever war I had with it and just say like, all right, how I made my mother, all right Ted, let's bring it in, you know, bring it in.
所以我只是，我想放弃我与之之间的任何战争，只是说，好吧，我是如何创造我的母亲的，好吧，特德，让我们把它带进来，你知道，把它带进来。
Let's see what we, let's see what's there.
让我们看看我们有什么，让我们看看那里有什么。
Yeah, I hope that will make this little exploration, this experiment we're doing of this podcast, sort of universal to people, even if it's not like himium super fans.
是的，我希望这将使这个小小的探索，我们正在做的播客实验，对人们来说具有普遍性，即使它不像 Himium 超级粉丝那样。
And like, I love that the himium super fans will listen, but it's also kind of a podcast about figuring out who you were in another chapter, and how does it fit in with who you are now.
就像，我喜欢 Himium 超级粉丝会听，但这也是一个播客，旨在了解你在另一章中是谁，以及它如何与你现在的身份相适应。
Yeah, I mean, all the grand of a life question.
是的，我的意思是，这是一个重大的人生问题。
All the grand themes of how I made my mother are at play right now in this podcast, and they will be as long as we do it, you know?
我如何塑造母亲的所有宏大主题现在都在这个播客中发挥作用，只要我们这样做，它们就会一直存在，你知道吗？
I do hope that there's people who've never watched the show who tune into this podcast and watch it with us.
我确实希望有从未看过该节目的人收听此播客并与我们一起观看。
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
Well, that brings me to my, that brings me to a question.
好吧，这让我想到了一个问题。
Yeah.
是的。
So Josh and I just played this wonderful chair.
所以乔什和我刚刚扮演了这把美妙的椅子。
And another thing that's emerged since how much your mother is, that Josh Radner has become an amazing musician, singer, songwriter.
自从你的母亲成为了一名伟大的音乐家以来，乔什·拉德纳（Josh Radner）已经成为一位了不起的音乐家、歌手、词曲作者。
And I have had the privilege of a few times now of playing music with him at these fan, fun, fan-based fundraisers we do for a really important cause that I will talk about at some other point.
我有幸在这些粉丝、有趣、基于粉丝的筹款活动中与他一起演奏了几次音乐，我们为一个非常重要的事业而举办，我将在其他时候谈论这个事业。
And we just did it.
我们就这么做了。
We just did a power ballroom and it sold out a month early because how much your mother fans are the best, as I said.
我们刚刚做了一个强力舞厅，它提前一个月就卖完了，因为正如我所说，你妈妈的粉丝是最好的。
And two different people there afterwards, two different fans told me they had just watched the series 13 times over.
后来有两个不同的人，两个不同的粉丝告诉我他们刚刚把这个系列看了 13 遍。
They thought they watched it 13 times.
他们认为自己看了 13 遍。
They just do the math on that.
他们只是对此进行数学计算。
My dream is to be 13 times 208 and failing.
我的梦想是 13 次 208，但失败了。
I'm an English major, but it's a lot.
我是英语专业的，但是很多。
And thank you for watching it that much.
非常感谢您的观看。
I haven't seen it that many times.
我还没见过那么多次。
I haven't done a rewatch in a long time.
我已经很久没有重温了。
Here's my question, tell the fans.
这是我的问题，请告诉粉丝们。
to tell the people listening.
告诉听的人。
How many times over has your wife, Jordana seen how I met your mother?
你的妻子乔丹娜看过多少次我是如何遇见你母亲的？
Wow.
哇。
So yeah, Jordana, my wife has seen how I met your mother it is zero times.
所以，是的，乔丹娜，我的妻子见过我是如何遇见你母亲的，这是零次。
She's never seen the show, which was probably a help in our courtship.
她从未看过这个节目，这可能对我们的求爱有帮助。
I find this, I just wanna say I find this so fascinating.
我发现了这一点，我只是想说我发现这很有趣。
So what's happening here?
那么这里发生了什么？
I just wanna lay it out for people.
我只是想把它摆出来给人们看。
Part of the reason we're doing this podcast is that you were talking to Jordana about this And saying, there's this crazy chapter of my life.
我们做这个播客的部分原因是你和乔丹娜谈论这件事并说，这是我生命中疯狂的一章。
You don't know anything about it.
你对此一无所知。
You worked for all that I think that she didn't know anything about it, because she just met you.
你为我付出的一切我想她对此一无所知，因为她刚刚认识你。
Everything you just said about carrying Ted and wearing Ted on your face, she fell in love with you.
你刚才说的关于带着泰德、把泰德戴在脸上的一切，她都爱上了你。
She did not know what the hell how much your mother was.
她根本不知道你妈妈到底多少钱。
It still does not, right?
还是不行，对吧？
You haven't started the real life.
你还没有开始真正的生活。
And it's also crazy, because she is a TV fan.
这也很疯狂，因为她是一个电视迷。
Yeah.
是的。
She watches a lot of shows.
她看很多节目。
This one just, she missed.
就这一件事，她错过了。
I'm so, one of the experiments of this too is Josh will now sit down.
我是这样的，这也是实验之一，乔什现在坐下来。
And you really like how I met your mother in the episode where Ted is dating Stella and Stella has not seen Star Wars and Ted is terrified to what if she watches Star Wars, one of my like go to my core movies and doesn't like it.
你真的很喜欢我在泰德和斯特拉约会的那一集中遇见你母亲的方式，而斯特拉没有看过《星球大战》，泰德很害怕如果她看《星球大战》怎么办，我喜欢看我的核心电影，但不喜欢它。
Do I have to break up with her?
我必须和她分手吗？
Forget that.
忘了那个吧。
That felt like high stakes in the moment when we were writing that as Star Wars nerds.
当我们作为《星球大战》的书呆子写这篇文章时，感觉风险很大。
But can you imagine the you're going to sit and watch how much of mother a decade of your life are going to sit and watch that with your wife.
但你能想象你将坐下来观看你生命中十年的母亲将与你的妻子一起坐下来观看这一切吗？
Is there pressure?
有压力吗？
Will that be a fun watch?
这会是一块有趣的手表吗？
Or will you be sort of side anger going like, is she liking this?
或者你会有点愤怒，比如，她喜欢这个吗？
I mean, I'm still fascinated by this.
我的意思是，我仍然对此着迷。
Probably watch her watch it quite a bit.
可能看她看了很多次。
I will say our relationship could withstand her not liking it, but I don't, I suspect she's not going to not like it.
我会说我们的关系可以承受她不喜欢，但我不喜欢，我怀疑她不会不喜欢。
Is that right?
是这样吗？
Is that what I mean to say?
这就是我想说的吗？
Yeah.
是的。
She's a psychologist.
她是一位心理学家。
She's incredibly obviously psychologically attuned, so she will understand the deeper aspects of the show for sure.
她在心理上有着令人难以置信的明显协调，所以她肯定会理解这部剧的更深层次。
But we are gonna have a section, we haven't worked out exactly how to do it, but we have a section called questions and observations from a clinical psychologist, relationship expert, who's never seen how I met your mother who also happens to be married to Josh.
但我们会有一个部分，我们还没有弄清楚具体该怎么做，但是我们有一个部分，叫做问题和观察，来自一位临床心理学家、关系专家，他从来没有见过我是如何认识你母亲的，她也碰巧嫁给了乔什。
Is that title too catchy?
这标题是不是太吸引人了？
Because that's just the best.
因为那只是最好的。
get an acronym for it.
获取它的缩写。
We'll just get an acronym for it and we'll be able to.
我们只要得到它的缩写就可以了。
It's almost as good as Hwimium, uh, Hwimium.
它几乎和 Hwimium 一样好，呃，Hwimium。
Yeah.
是的。
Uh, I love that.
呃，我喜欢那个。
I mean, my, like, my way for Becca, who, and I guess I should've said this sooner, she, she, the two of us are kind of like Marshall and Lily, right?
我的意思是，我，就像，我对贝卡的方式，我想我应该早点说这个，她，她，我们两个有点像马歇尔和莉莉，对吧？
It's, we met in Wesleyan University, we're being together that whole time.
我们是在卫斯理大学认识的，我们一直在一起。
And we were like the old married couple in our late 20s.
我们就像是二十多岁的老夫妻。
And that was part of the impetus of how much mother and the characters create the creation of those characters.
这也是母亲和角色创造这些角色的部分动力。
She is so annoyed because she only ever watched every episode once and she said, here's how I watched every episode.
她很生气，因为她每集只看了一次，她说，这就是我每集的观看方式。
It would be Monday night.
那是星期一晚上。
I would be airing.
我会播出。
You'd be sitting next to me, staring at me, seeing if I laughed at the right spots.
你会坐在我旁边，盯着我看，看看我是否在正确的地方笑了。
You would say, did we sound mix that wrong?
你可能会说，我们的混音听起来是不是错了？
You didn't hear, I think you didn't hear that line because you didn't laugh and she'd be like, I didn't laugh because it wasn't that, it's not, it's not all gold.
你没有听到，我想你没有听到那句话，因为你没有笑，她会说，我没有笑，因为它不是那样，它不是，它不全是金子。
It's not all gold, dude.
这并不都是金子，伙计。
And I asked her like, is the music too hot there compared to the dialogue and she'll be like, I don't, I don't care.
我问她，与对话相比，音乐是否太热了，她会说，我不，我不在乎。
I just want to watch it.
我只是想看看。
Stop it.
停止吧。
So that was her great, she, she watched for nine years like that.
所以这就是她的伟大,她她就这样看了九年。
And has basically never seen episodes besides that.
除此之外基本上没看过剧集。
And she has been asking for years, like can we dive back in, can we do the rewatch?
多年来她一直在问，比如我们可以重新投入，我们可以重新观看吗？
And I don't know for whatever reason I just didn't, I didn't do it.
我不知道出于什么原因我没有这样做。
I don't know why.
我不知道为什么。
Maybe I'm was waiting for a round number, was waiting for these tens and what he's probably, I know this from watching, you know, films I made, like you stopped thinking about the mix 10 years later.
也许我正在等待一个整数，正在等待这几十个以及他可能是什么，我通过观看我制作的电影知道这一点，就像十年后你不再考虑混合一样。
Right.
正确的。
You know, you'll Just the bad joke you you're like that Joe could have been funnier and then you see it later and you're like That was a good joke.
你知道，你会开个糟糕的玩笑，乔本来可以更有趣，然后你稍后看到它，你会觉得这是一个好笑话。
What the fuck is it?
这他妈是什么？
And now commercials I could talk for hours about every single episode of how I met your mother and we do But when it comes to my own health, I used to be pretty clueless.
现在，我可以在广告中谈论几个小时，讲述我如何遇见你母亲以及我们之间的每一集，但当涉及到我自己的健康时，我曾经非常无能。
I'd shrug off low energy, or a fitness plateau is just stress, basically guessing about what my body actually needed.
我会摆脱低能量，或者健身平台只是压力，基本上猜测我的身体实际需要什么。
But you shouldn't guess when it comes to your health.
但当涉及到您的健康时，您不应该猜测。
Instead, you should get the real data that supports your wellness with lab core on-demand health testing.
相反，您应该通过实验室核心按需健康测试来获取支持您健康的真实数据。
On the website, you can choose from a suite of more than 100 health tests, including Micronutrient, Allergy, Testosterone, Fitness, Sexual Wellness, and more all available to purchase without a doctor's appointment.
在该网站上，您可以从 100 多种健康测试中进行选择，包括微量营养素、过敏、睾酮、健身、性健康等，无需医生预约即可购买。
Just purchase a test online and visit a local lab core location to have your sample collected.
只需在线购买测试并访问当地实验室核心地点即可收集样本。
It's so simple.
就是这么简单。
With the days, you'll have accurate results that are easy to understand from a lab doctor's trust.
随着时间的推移，您将获得实验室医生信任的易于理解的准确结果。
Your journey visit ondemand.labcore.com slash mother and use code mother to save up to 15% on select tests.
您的旅程访问 ondemand.labcore.com 削减 mother 并使用 code mother 可以在特定测试中节省高达 15% 的费用。
That's ondemand.labcore.com slash mother and use code mother.
这就是 ondemand.labcore.com 斜线母亲和使用代码母亲。
Know yourself.
了解你自己。
Hey Craig, you know now that I have a child, a baby in the house, you know what I'm finding it hard to do?
嘿克雷格，你现在知道我有一个孩子了，家里有一个婴儿，你知道我觉得做什么很难吗？
What?
什么？
To remember to do?
要记得做什么？
What's that?
那是什么？
Eat food.
吃食物。
that's one of the basic needs that is no longer the priority.
这是基本需求之一，但不再是优先事项。
I know, and I forget.
我知道，但我忘记了。
It's like, oh, I forgot to feed Nelson, my dog, and myself.
就像，哦，我忘了喂尼尔森、我的狗和我自己。
So how are we going to solve that problem?
那么我们要如何解决这个问题呢？
Well, I just need something just quick on the go that I won't, no must, no fuss.
好吧，我只是需要一些快速的东西，我不会，没有必要，不用大惊小怪。
I just need to feed myself and get some energy so I can get back to parenting.
我只需要养活自己并获得一些能量，这样我就可以回去养育孩子了。
Yes, and so what would solve that problem?
是的，那么什么可以解决这个问题呢？
I'm going to steer you towards an outcome and the outcome is this product you're about to mention.
我将引导您走向一个结果，而这个结果就是您将要提到的这款产品。
Oh, oh, wait, are you talking about Bavarian meats a little lamb, yeager, snacks, sticks?
哦，哦，等等，你是在说巴伐利亚肉、小羊肉、耶格啤酒、零食、肉棒吗？
We agreed, that's what, right before we started talking to Zoe said, that's what we're gonna talk about.
我们同意，这就是我们开始与佐伊交谈之前所说的，这就是我们要谈论的内容。
Well, this is what I wanna talk about.
嗯，这就是我想谈的。
The great tasting Bavarian meats, little lamb, yeager, snacks, sticks.
美味的巴伐利亚肉类、小羊肉、耶格啤酒、小吃、肉棒。
They sent us some of these and they are delicious and they solve the central problem of my life, which is I forget to eat.
他们给我们送来了一些，它们很美味，解决了我生活中的核心问题，那就是我忘记吃饭。
They're naturally fermented.
它们是自然发酵的。
They're made with real ingredients, slow smoked for bold flavor pack with nine grams of protein per serving and have zero sugar and zero carbs.
它们采用真正的原料制成，经过慢熏，味道浓郁，每份含有 9 克蛋白质，并且零糖和零碳水化合物。
Also, I have a 19 year old boy.
另外，我有一个19岁的男孩。
Also a good moment to get a bunch of this product because he will eat us out of house and home.
这也是购买一堆这种产品的好时机，因为他会把我们吃得满屋子和家里。
And he loves this stuff.
他喜欢这个东西。
It's so great.
太棒了。
I'm very grateful we got to sample this.
我非常感激我们能品尝到这个。
My son is gonna eat it all.
我儿子会把它全部吃掉。
I'm gonna have none of it.
我将一无所有。
But okay, it's a snack that keeps up with your day, whether you're racing between meetings or feeding babies or 19 year olds.
但没关系，无论您是在赶会议还是在给婴儿或 19 岁的孩子喂奶，它都是一款适合您一天的零食。
Doing school drop-off, just trying to finish your to-do list, take a moment to savor something delicious for you, or your children, and did we mention they're portable?
送学，只是想完成您的待办事项清单，花点时间为您或您的孩子品尝美味的东西，我们是否提到过它们是便携式的？
Toss a few in your glove box, your gym bag, the diaper bag, wherever.
在您的手套箱、健身包、尿布包中或任何地方都扔一些。
We have a diaper bag.
我们有一个尿布袋。
I bet you do, better.
我打赌你会的，而且会更好。
Two or three of those bad boys.
两三个坏男孩。
Pick up a pack today, your local grocer, or stock up at bavarianmeats.com slash podcast.
立即从当地杂货店购买一包，或在 bavarianmeats.com 斜线播客上购买。
Use code mother10mother10 at checkout for 10% off your first order.
结帐时使用代码 mother10mother10，首次订单可享受 10% 折扣。
the very in meat snack, sticks, great taste, zero sugar.
非常有肉味的零食，棒棒哒，味道好极了，零糖。
End of commercials back to show.
广告结束返回放映。
But here's a thing that we were starting to unpack in a talk, but we said, ah, let's save it for the show.
但这是我们在一次演讲中开始解开的一件事，但我们说，啊，让我们把它留到节目中吧。
And we can also dip into this with Carter, but it's so fascinating to me that you guys were the age of the characters you were writing essentially.
我们也可以和卡特一起探讨这个问题，但这对我来说太有趣了，因为你们基本上就是你们所写角色的年龄。
Yeah.
是的。
And yet it was framed as a flashback from an older wiser man who was offering this kind of wisdom and perspective born of his years of being farther along and being able to look back and contextualize it.
然而，它被认为是一位年长智者的闪回，他提供了这种智慧和观点，这些智慧和观点源于他多年来的走得更远，能够回顾过去并将其置于背景中。
And so you were having to, from inside of the experience, you were having to almost beam your consciousness forward 20 or 25 years and reflect back on the moment you were in, which is like a heroic amount to ask, I think of anyone much less young kids running their first TV show, were you conscious of the weirdness of that?
所以你不得不，从经历的内部，你不得不几乎把你的意识投射到20或25年之前，并回想你所处的那一刻，这就像一个英雄般的问题，我认为任何人，尤其是小孩子，运行他们的第一个电视节目，你意识到这很奇怪吗？
It seems weirder now, in a way.
在某种程度上，现在看起来更奇怪了。
It almost didn't seem that weird at the time.
当时看起来几乎没有那么奇怪。
And I think it's because we fancied ourselves older than our years.
我认为这是因为我们幻想自己比实际年龄更老。
I think, yeah, we were like 32 writing 52 or something, right?
我想，是的，我们就像 32 岁写 52 岁之类的，对吧？
When we were writing, thinking about future Ted's perspectives and his mid-50s, whatever he is, we're now far closer to that.
当我们写作时，思考未来特德的观点和他 50 多岁的人，无论他是什么，我们现在已经更接近那个目标了。
And I look back at it and I do think it had something to do with wanting, being drawn to the idea of reassurance of the future.
回顾过去，我确实认为这与想要、被对未来放心的想法所吸引有关。
There's a future you, because you feel so lost when you're 30, right?
未来的你是有的，因为30岁的时候你会感到很失落，对吗？
You're not actually quite an adult, right?
其实你还没有成年，对吧？
We were, we all felt like frauds.
我们，我们都觉得自己像个骗子。
We were all the same age, we were all these little kids.
我们都是同龄人，我们都是小孩子。
We somehow fooled our way into having a TV show.
我们不知何故搞了一个电视节目。
And like we, I think we were just imagining our future selves telling us what we wanted to hear now in this moment because we felt lost, because we felt scared, because we felt haunted.
就像我们一样，我认为我们只是想象未来的自己告诉我们现在想听到什么，因为我们感到失落，因为我们感到害怕，因为我们感到困扰。
And that idea of that future Ted gave us so much confidence.
特德对未来的想法给了我们很大的信心。
Like it just, it sort of lifted us up to be looking through that lens.
就像它一样，它有点让我们通过这个镜头来观察。
And by pretending to be that thing, we sort of became that thing.
通过假装成为那个东西，我们就变成了那个东西。
And that's so great.
那真是太棒了。
Now we're sort of the age, almost the age of the of future Ted.
现在我们已经到了这个时代，几乎是未来特德的时代。
And I still feel just about as confused as I ever did about life.
我仍然像以前一样对生活感到困惑。
But I feel a little older and a little wiser.
但我感觉自己老了一些，也聪明了一些。
And I think another big part of it was, We were aware, we were, Carden and I, we're big thinkers, we're overthinkers, and we were very aware that a chapter of our lives had ended.
我认为其中的另一个重要部分是，我们意识到，我们，卡登和我，我们是伟大的思想家，我们是过度思考者，我们非常清楚我们生命中的一个章节已经结束了。
The 20s in New York part had ended.
20 世纪 20 年代的纽约部分已经结束。
We were writers for David Letterman, and we made this leap, and this will be a very heavy thing to bring up and talking about a sitcom, but we, you know, 9-11 happened a little bit before, like that happened right before we moved to LA.
我们是大卫·莱特曼的编剧，我们实现了这一飞跃，提起并谈论一部情景喜剧将是一件非常沉重的事情，但我们，你知道，9-11 事件发生过一段时间，就像我们搬到洛杉矶之前发生的那样。
And there was, this is feeling in New York City sort of writ large that something had ended.
在纽约市，有一种明显的感觉，那就是某些事情已经结束了。
Some era had ended, something had changed that was not gonna change back.
某个时代已经结束，有些事情已经发生了改变，并且不会再变回来。
And then we found ourselves living in Los Angeles trying to think of a pilot idea to write.
然后我们发现自己住在洛杉矶，试图想出一个写作的试点想法。
And we wrote about this nostalgia for our 20s in New York when we were like 30 and one day old.
我们写了关于我们 20 多岁时在纽约的怀旧之情，当时我们才 30 岁零一天。
We didn't, we were nostalgic for our 20s in New York immediately.
但我们没有，我们立即怀念20多岁的纽约时光。
And but nostalgic for like a time before this horrible tragedy hadn't happened, right?
但怀念这起可怕的悲剧没有发生之前的一段时光，对吧？
We were still writing for Letterman when 9-11 happened And then we left to move to LA the spring after that, like the spring of 2002.
9·11 事件发生时，我们仍在为莱特曼写作，之后的春天，比如 2002 年的春天，我们离开并搬到了洛杉矶。
And I just think the sort of grabby tasks and the instant requirement to become more of a grown-up from living through 9-11 in New York and the instant nostalgia and the desire to sort of have things make sense or be back in some simpler time, inhabit a different time in your brain and your memories when things didn't feel the way they felt after 9-11.
我只是认为，在经历了纽约的“9·11”事件之后，那种抓紧的任务、想要变得更加成熟的即时要求，以及瞬间的怀旧和想要让事情变得有意义或回到某个更简单的时间的渴望，在你的大脑和记忆中占据了一个不同的时间，当事情不像9·11之后那样的时候。
And I think that weirdly really informed the show.
我认为这确实奇怪地告诉了这部剧。
It made us like maybe a little older than our years, and it made us a little more reflective, a little more nostalgic.
它让我们感觉自己比实际年龄老了一点，也让我们多了一点反思，多了一点怀旧。
And I think part of that is how we accessed writing from that future perspective, even when we were in our thirties and we're pretend to be the old wise guy.
我认为其中一部分是我们如何从未来的角度来看待写作，即使我们已经三十多岁了，我们假装自己是一个聪明的老家伙。
But somehow we could sort of fake our way into being that at least on paper.
但不知何故，我们可以假装成为这样的人，至少在纸面上是这样。
And I sometimes people will quote lines from future to tell me and say that got them through a really hard time.
有时人们会引用未来的台词来告诉我，并说这让他们度过了一段非常艰难的时期。
Thank you for those wise words and I'm talking.
谢谢你的智慧之言，我正在说话。
We were like 31 wishing we had that wisdom and sort of like play acting it, but it worked somehow, right?
我们就像 31 岁的人一样希望自己拥有这种智慧，并且有点像演戏一样，但它不知何故奏效了，对吧？
It feels to me like Kenneth Branagh at 31 playing Lear, and you're like, what are you doing?
对我来说，这感觉就像 31 岁的肯尼思·布拉纳 (Kenneth Branagh) 扮演李尔王 (Lear)，然后你就会想，你在做什么？
But also it's like he's good at it.
但也好像他很擅长。
Right.
正确的。
And he sort of, and does it elevate you?
他有点这样，这会让你提升吗？
It's sort of that idea of like the fake until you make a thing.
在你制造出东西之前，这有点像假货。
Like it somehow it elevated us and made us feel like we really were that older, was it?
就像它以某种方式提升了我们，让我们感觉自己真的老了，不是吗？
You know, speaking of, of Jordan, it seems like where we talk you about a bit, she has a thing which she'll sometimes say to her patients.
你知道，说到乔丹，似乎在我们谈论你的地方，她有时会对她的病人说一些话。
If someone's really confused, really tied and not about something, she'll say, what is your 85 year old self say?
如果有人真的很困惑，真的很束缚并且不关心某件事，她会说，你85岁的自己会说什么？
She's gonna like him in.
她会喜欢他的。
She didn't like the show.
她不喜欢这个节目。
Yeah, but if it's a great question.
是的，但如果这是一个很好的问题。
And she said, if you ask yourself, what is my 85 year old self?
她说，如果你问自己，85岁的我是什么样的？
It all, the answer comes real fast.
一切，答案来得很快。
And it's real service.
这是真正的服务。
Yes, yes, yes.
是的，是的，是的。
And I think, you know, I mentioned this that piece I wrote about Ted for my muse letters, but Dick Schwartz has the thing internal family systems, IFS, which is like really it's called parts work and you're locating these parts of yourself that are sometimes at odds with each other, but they're all in you.
我想，你知道，我在为我的缪斯信件写的关于泰德的那篇文章中提到了这一点，但迪克施瓦茨有内部家庭系统，IFS，这就像真的它被称为部分工作，你正在定位自己的这些部分，有时彼此不一致，但它们都在你身上。
And it strikes me that you and Carter like, and me too, we have an elder in us.
让我印象深刻的是，你和卡特都喜欢，我也喜欢，我们身上有一位长辈。
Right.
正确的。
We have an older, I don't know if it's ancestral or just a wise old, something connected more towards the bigger picture the perennial kind of wisdom.
我们有一个更古老的，我不知道它是祖传的还是只是一个智慧的老人，一些与更大的图景更相关的东西，即永恒的智慧。
And we can go there.
我们可以去那里。
We can we can access it at 31 or 30 whenever you guys were writing.
每当你们写作时，我们都可以在 31 或 30 访问它。
The other thing that I don't know if it was you or Carter, but first season what year was older Ted narrating, 2030?
另一件事情，我不知道是你还是卡特，但第一季是哪一年，泰德旁白是 2030 年？
2030, yeah.
2030 年，是的。
2030.
2030年。
So one of you guys said it's actually actually the most optimistic show in the world because it's saying the world will still be here in 2030, like they'll still be fathers talking to their kids in 2030.
所以你们中的一个人说这实际上是世界上最乐观的节目，因为它说世界在 2030 年仍然存在，就像他们在 2030 年仍然是父亲与孩子交谈一样。
Yeah.
是的。
No.
不。
We and we would make the joke because it is inspiring to think of and then we'd make the joke, but also like we can end the series where you realize like Ted is telling future Ted is telling his kids that story like a mile underground, the surface of the earth and I'm like, he's going to get in the shelter.
我们和我们会开这个玩笑，因为想到它很鼓舞人心，然后我们会开这个玩笑，但也就像我们可以在这个系列结束时，你意识到泰德正在告诉未来，泰德正在告诉他的孩子们这个故事，就像地下一英里，地球表面一样，我想，他会进入避难所。
Serves and it's just like the machines have risen up and killed us.
发球了，就像机器起来杀死我们一样。
But yeah, like that idea, there will always be future you there to tell your story.
但是，是的，就像这个想法一样，未来总会有你在那里讲述你的故事。
There's a future version of you to whom this all makes more sense.
对未来版本的你来说，这一切都更有意义。
And that is just so much more generous and has such gratitude for even the low moments.
这更加慷慨，即使在低谷时刻也充满感激之情。
Looking back.
回头看。
I think the thing you're describing is that I think open my heart the most to the series.
我认为你所描述的事情是我认为对这个系列最开放的。
And I don't know how much I sense from the pilot, but I think it's all there.
我不知道我从飞行员身上感受到了多少，但我想一切都在那里。
The DNA of the whole show is in the pilot, which we'll be unpacking.
整个节目的 DNA 都在试播集中，我们将对其进行解压。
But it's a fundamentally optimistic show at its core.
但这本质上是一部乐观的剧。
It is not a nihilistic cynical show.
这不是一场虚无主义的愤世嫉俗的表演。
It's a show about decent people and even Barney who's like somewhat of a sociopathic criminal based on episode, based on, you know, whatever episode he's in, has a core of sweetness about him.
这是一部关于正派人的节目，甚至巴尼也像一个反社会的罪犯，基于剧集，基于，你知道，无论他在哪一集，他都有一个甜蜜的核心。
Yeah, and the way Neil played it kind of with a wink that maybe helped him get away, you guys all get away with a lot.
是的，尼尔眨眼的方式可能帮助他逃脱，你们都逃脱了很多。
But it's a fundamentally optimistic show and I just, I liked being both for professional reasons but more almost like for personal reasons.
但这从根本上来说是一个乐观的节目，我只是因为职业原因而喜欢，但更像是出于个人原因。
Like I'm really conscious of what I'm putting into the collective.
就像我真的很清楚我为集体付出了什么。
Like I want and you know how I made your mother made some missteps and stumbles and we're going to unpack all of those.
就像我想要的那样，你知道我是如何让你母亲犯下一些错误和绊脚石的，我们将解开所有这些。
But generally I felt like it's feet were pointed in a really good direction and it's heart was in the right place.
但总的来说，我觉得它的脚指向了一个非常好的方向，它的心脏也处于正确的位置。
Also how narratively invented it was, you know, there was something like 40 to 60 scenes in an average how I made my mother.
另外，它是如何叙事性地发明的，你知道，我塑造母亲的过程中平均有 40 到 60 个场景。
The record was 80.
记录是80。
The record was 83.
记录是83。
In 21 minutes, 21.5 minutes basically you're doing 81 scenes or 60 scenes or 50 scenes like it's a lot.
在 21 分钟、21.5 分钟内，基本上你要做 81 个场景、60 个场景或 50 个场景，好像很多。
Alec, you have a question.
亚历克，你有一个问题。
By the way, I will say Alec Lev is chiming up a little comment.
顺便说一句，我想说亚历克·列夫正在发表一些评论。
Alec worked on the show multiple seasons as our new media coordinator.
亚历克作为我们的新媒体协调员参与了该剧多个季的工作。
He did the in production podcast, which we did for a few years on the show and he did all the sort of internet presence and DVD extras and all the stuff.
他制作了制作中的播客，我们在节目中做了几年，他还制作了所有的互联网节目和 DVD 附加节目以及所有的东西。
So Alec is also a himium alum, which I failed to say.
所以Alec也是一名hiium明矾，这一点我没有说出来。
Alec, what do you want to say?
亚历克，你想说什么？
And you and I also shared a cat.
你和我还共用一只猫。
We went to college and lived together all four years.
我们上大学并一起生活了四年。
And one time I was hanging out with Alec and a bunch of people and he said, he introduced me forgetting that we went to college together.
有一次我和亚历克以及一群人一起出去玩，他说，他介绍我时忘记了我们一起上过大学。
He started explaining what Wesleyan is.
他开始解释卫斯理安是什么。
He said to other people that we were standing with, they went to us and he was like, we all went to college together.
他对其他人说，我们和我们站在一起，他们走向我们，他说，我们一起上大学。
Wesleyan, I'm like, yeah, asshole.
卫斯理，我想，是的，混蛋。
I was, I was there.
我当时，我就在那里。
You don't have to tell me that.
你不必告诉我这一点。
Anyways, Alex, go ahead.
无论如何，亚历克斯，继续吧。
Well, no, I just want to, so, so this podcast I want to hear a little bit as we, as we wrap up this first episode of what, what people can expect from this version of a rewatch podcast.
好吧，不，我只是想，所以，所以这个播客，当我们结束第一集时，我想听听一点，人们可以从这个版本的重播播客中期待什么。
If you've heard other ones where people go episode by episode.
如果您听说过其他人一集一集地去的地方。
We are going to do that next week.
我们将在下周这样做。
You're going to hear Carter Bayes.
你会听到卡特·贝叶斯的讲话。
We've talked a lot about Carter.
我们已经谈论了很多关于卡特的事情。
Carter's going to join us to talk about the creation of how I met your mother and all these questions that you guys have been asking.
卡特将和我们一起谈论我如何认识你母亲的故事以及你们一直在问的所有这些问题。
And then from there, we'll be going episode by episode.
然后从那里开始，我们将一集接着一集。
But can you talk a little bit about what people are going to hear that you know of?
但您能谈谈您所知道的人们将会听到的内容吗？
Because of course, we don't quite know where we're going, exactly.
因为当然，我们不太清楚我们要去哪里。
But Josh, talk a little bit about what's coming up.
但是乔希，请谈谈即将发生的事情。
Yeah.
是的。
I know this is a big fun trend that people or really liking these rewatch podcasts.
我知道这是一个很有趣的趋势，人们或真正喜欢这些播客的人会重新观看。
I have to confess, I've never listened to a single one of them.
我必须承认，我从来没有听过他们中的任何一个。
I don't know, I know it's happening.
我不知道，我知道它正在发生。
I don't know what other people are doing.
我不知道其他人在做什么。
I just know what I like to talk about with Craig.
我只知道我喜欢和克雷格谈论什么。
I have, and Craig has some special insight into this particular show.
我有，克雷格对这个特殊的节目有一些特殊的见解。
I think that some episodes will be more very specifically about the episode.
我认为有些剧集会更具体地讲述该剧集。
I imagine, you know, when we get to drumroll please, right, we'll like talk very deeply about that episode.
我想，你知道，当我们开始鼓掌时，我们会非常深入地讨论这一集。
It's a pretty iconic one.
这是一个非常具有标志性的。
I remember, I think this is true that they could analyze the data, like once it went up maybe on Netflix and drumroll please was the one that was like the huckiest episode, like it was the one that made people want to watch more or something.
我记得，我认为这是真的，他们可以分析数据，就像一旦它在 Netflix 上播出，请鼓乐是最搞笑的一集，就像是让人们想观看更多或其他内容的一集。
I don't know.
我不知道。
That's right.
这是正确的。
But then there are other ones that maybe are a little less dense that might just inspire another talk.
但还有其他一些可能不太密集的内容可能会激发另一场讨论。
So like if you're tuning in with us, you're going to hear a lot of talk about how I mean, but you're also going to hear us muse about different things, you know, different.
所以，如果你收听我们的节目，你会听到很多关于我的意思的讨论，但你也会听到我们对不同事物的思考，你知道，不同的。
We're, we, I want us to be open to talk about our own lives to talk about.
我们，我们，我希望我们能够开诚布公地谈论我们自己的生活。
It's not going to be super current, a Pharisee because I think like one of the things I love about how I made other mother is the part of it that ages well in terms of, um, you know, it wasn't, there wasn't a lot of tech in how I made it.
它不会是超级潮流，法利赛人，因为我认为我喜欢我如何创造另一个母亲的事情之一就是它的一部分，嗯，你知道，它不是，我的制作方式没有太多技术。
Well, I mean, it was things that that will be perennially relevant, right?
嗯，我的意思是，这些事情将永远相关，对吧？
So, I think we, if you want to watch along or re-watch along with us, there's going to be a lot of talk about certain episodes, certain jokes, where it came to funny offstage anecdotes, anecdotes, inside baseball stuff, that will be really fun for the superfan.
所以，我认为，如果你想和我们一起观看或重新观看，将会有很多关于某些剧集、某些笑话的讨论，其中涉及有趣的台下轶事、轶事、棒球内部的东西，这对超级粉丝来说真的很有趣。
But also, I hope it's just just a fun, you know, getting to spend some time with us, you know, in a way that feels nourishing and insightful and just like a breezy good time, you know.
而且，我希望这只是一种乐趣，你知道，与我们一起度过一些时间，你知道，以一种感觉滋润和富有洞察力的方式，就像一段轻松愉快的时光，你知道。
Yeah.
是的。
And I think there's going to be some looking back with different eyes.
我认为会有一些人以不同的眼光回顾过去。
I think there'll be some owning of some moments that didn't age as well, even though I hope the show is timeless.
我认为，尽管我希望这部剧是永恒的，但也会有一些不那么古老的时刻。
I think there's going to be some, a few like apologies to people whose stories we stole without asking.
我认为会有一些类似的事情，比如向那些我们未经询问就窃取了故事的人道歉。
I was terrible at that.
我对此感到很糟糕。
I would just take people's life stories.
我只会拍摄人们的生活故事。
That's funny.
那很好笑。
Put it on TV.
把它放到电视上。
And then I wouldn't tell the person that's until they saw the house going on here.
然后我不会告诉那个人，直到他们看到这里的房子正在建设。
So if you're wondering where he got the idea for a married couple sharing a toothbrush, just tune it.
所以，如果你想知道他从哪里得到了一对已婚夫妇共用牙刷的想法，那就调整一下吧。
Well, we'll, we'll, we'll dive in.
好吧，我们会，我们会，我们会潜入。
And that's spoilers.
这是剧透。
It's all like, and let's just, let's just, let's just go there.
一切就像，我们就这样，我们就这样，我们就去那里吧。
Why are we going to wait?
我们为什么要等待？
Someone watched it and said it's pronounced chameleon.
有人看了后说它是变色龙。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
I definitely want to talk about that one.
我绝对想谈谈这个。
But yeah, yeah, I think it's gonna be fun.
但是，是的，是的，我想这会很有趣。
It's gonna be fun to look back on it.
回顾起来会很有趣。
And sometimes it'll be very much about the episode.
有时它会与剧集有关。
Sometimes it'll just be us like, what did the topic of that episode make us think about at the time and now?
有时我们会想，那一集的主题让我们当时和现在想到了什么？
And how do we look at it now?
而我们现在又如何看待它呢？
And how much, I wanna talk also about what of our lives at the time made it onto the show.
我还想谈谈我们当时的生活是怎样出现在节目中的。
And what it was happening in our own personal lives that informed the show.
以及我们个人生活中发生的事情为这部剧提供了信息。
Like I, yeah, I went through a lot during how I met your mother.
就像我一样，是的，在遇见你母亲的过程中我经历了很多。
as did we all, nine years ago through a lot of stuff and basically 10 years door to door.
就像我们所有人一样，九年前经历了很多事情，基本上是十年前挨家挨户的经历。
And yeah, I wanna talk about that stuff.
是的，我想谈谈这些事情。
And also how you as writers start paying attention very keenly to us as actors and how that changes how you write the character.
以及作为作家的你如何开始非常敏锐地关注我们作为演员，以及这如何改变你写角色的方式。
Yeah.
是的。
You know, there were certain things I remember, I remember like sometimes you'll get a big laugh at a run through, like a network run through, and I'll just be like, oh, they're gonna, and I remember when I walked in return of the shirt, which for some reason I have very big fondness for.
你知道，有些事情我记得，我记得有时你会因为跑步而大笑，就像网络跑步一样，我会说，哦，他们会的，我记得当我走回衬衫时，出于某种原因我非常喜欢这件衬衫。
But when I walked in and Marshall said, hot top, bro.
但当我走进去时，马歇尔说，热顶，兄弟。
Do you remember that one?
你还记得那个吗？
And I just said, right, right.
我只是说，对，对。
And for some reason, right, right became a kind of...
出于某种原因，对，对变成了一种......
It was like a catchphrase.
这就像一句流行语。
It was a low key catchphrase.
这是一个低调的口号。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
And I think that was one of the first times I said, but I remember people just...
我想这是我第一次这么说，但我记得人们只是......
I say that all the time.
我一直这么说。
Just like laughed so hard as they're right, right?
就像他们笑得很厉害一样，对吧？
We did that all the time.
我们一直都是这么做的。
That is a, like if that, that's a low key in your catchphrase.
That is a，就像 if that，这在你的口号中是低调的。
I'm glad you put it that one out.
我很高兴你把它拿出来了。
I definitely still say that.
我肯定还是这么说。
And that was, that was your, did you improvise that?
那是，那是你的，是你即兴创作的吗？
I don't feel like we wrote, did we write it?
我感觉不是我们写的，是我们写的吗？
I don't remember, I have, we might have written it, but I have one in my mind, people say, did you ever write on the show?
我不记得了，我有，我们可能写过，但我心里有一个，人们说，你在节目上写过吗？
And I said, one line.
我说，一行。
And it was, I dropped, what was the thing where I had to climb in the mailbox?
是的，我掉了下来，我必须爬进邮箱的东西是什么？
And I got stuck in the mailbox.
我被困在邮箱里了。
What was that?
那是什么？
literally blanking on what the context of the New York street and I dropped in a letter to the mailbox and then I realized that I needed to get it out.
我对纽约街道的背景完全茫然，我把一封信扔到邮箱里，然后我意识到我需要把它拿出来。
I shouldn't have mailed it.
我不应该邮寄它。
But I remember I I did the rehearsal and I went up to either you or Carter whoever was on set and I said, can I drop it in and say mailed it?
但我记得我排练过，然后我去找你或卡特，无论是谁在片场，我说，我可以把它放进去并说邮寄吗？
Oh my god.
我的天啊。
That was my one big improv that made it.
这是我做出的一大改进。
I just speak that.
我只是说说而已。
I feel like there were many more than that.
我感觉还有很多。
But that's a good.
但这是好事。
Oh, maybe, maybe.
哦，也许，也许。
So I just want to add here about all the ways that listeners can interact with the show because from the very beginning, you've both been saying you want this very much to be a show for not just for the fans, but sort of buy them as well.
所以我只想在这里补充一下听众与节目互动的所有方式，因为从一开始，你们就一直在说，你们非常希望这不仅是一场为粉丝而做的节目，而且也为他们买单。
And if you go to our website, how we made your mother.com, you're going to find a way that you can send us a message and tell us your story and you can tell us a story just about how I met your mother in general or there's even ways for you to talk about specific episodes send in an audio message to us like you heard at the beginning of this show you can also write us a message and we'll read a lot of those like a lot of them like we really want to hear from you also the home of this show on online is really going to be on substack and you can find a link to that on our website.
如果你访问我们的网站，我们是如何创建你的 mother.com 的，你会找到一种方式，你可以向我们发送消息，告诉我们你的故事，你可以告诉我们一个关于我如何认识你母亲的故事，或者甚至可以让你谈论特定的情节，向我们发送音频消息，就像你在这个节目开始时听到的那样，你也可以给我们写一条消息，我们会读到很多这样的消息，就像我们真的很想听到你的消息一样，也是这个节目的主页on online 确实会在 substack 上，您可以在我们的网站上找到该链接。
Josh is on substack and you can read his newsletters and then you'll also be able to read about the show.
乔什在子堆栈上，您可以阅读他的时事通讯，然后您还可以阅读有关该节目的信息。
Josh and Craig are going to write a little bit about each episode.
乔什和克雷格将针对每一集写一些内容。
You'll get the show notes there and maybe other ways to interact and of course we're all over social media.
您会在那里获得演出笔记，也许还有其他互动方式，当然我们都在社交媒体上。
So if you just go over to howwemadeyourmother.com and you're going to find all of those ways to be a part of how we made your mother.
因此，如果您访问 howwemadeyourmother.com，您就会发现所有这些方法都可以成为我们创造您母亲的一部分。
Yeah.
是的。
And we really want to encourage people to kind of like join the community of this thing.
我们真的想鼓励人们加入这个社区。
And kind of, you know, collect an archive of like, this is what the show is and was and remains to us.
有点，你知道，收集类似的档案，这就是这个节目对我们来说是、过去和现在的样子。
But we love the idea of you guys feeling like it's us doing this, but you're with us, you know.
但我们喜欢这样的想法：你们感觉是我们在做这件事，但你们和我们在一起，你知道。
So participate, join us, tell your friends, we're really excited.
所以参与进来，加入我们，告诉你的朋友，我们真的很兴奋。
We're soliciting kind of testimonials about how I met your mother and what it's meant to people and that we really want this to be a feature of the show.
我们正在征求有关我如何认识你母亲以及这对人们意味着什么的推荐，我们真的希望这成为该节目的一个特色。
We want to hear from you out there, um, how you discovered the show, what it's meant to you.
我们想听听您的意见，嗯，您是如何发现这个节目的，它对您意味着什么。
So I'm just going to read one because maybe we'll make this a regular feature.
所以我只想读一篇，因为也许我们会让它成为一项常规功能。
Um, but this one says, Hey, Josh, I'm sending you this message from France.
嗯，但是这个人说，嘿，乔希，我从法国给你发了这条消息。
I don't know if you really love being recognized as Ted Mosby, but today I want to talk to you about it.
我不知道你是否真的喜欢被称为 Ted Mosby，但今天我想和你谈谈这个问题。
I need to talk to you about it because tonight for the third time, I finished how I met your mother and for the third time I cried a lot.
我需要和你谈谈这件事，因为今晚我第三次讲完我是如何见到你母亲的，第三次我哭了很多。
I'm 17 and I really grew up watching this series and I mean in every way possible.
我今年 17 岁，我真的是看着这个系列节目长大的，我的意思是在所有可能的方面。
I went through a lot of very bad times and you were always there to make me laugh and believe again.
我经历了很多非常糟糕的时光，你总是在那里让我开怀大笑，让我再次相信。
You were there to instruct me really important things about life every episode had something to teach me.
你在那里教我关于生活的真正重要的事情，每一集都有一些东西可以教给我。
Like I just like your character believe a lot in destiny.
就像我喜欢你的性格一样相信命运。
Maybe too much.
也许太多了。
I love too much.
我太爱了。
I do everything too much.
我做的一切都太多了。
And sometimes I'm worrying if I shouldn't just stop.
有时我会担心我是否不应该停下来。
But thanks to how I met your mother, I'll never worry again, because this is me and I'm never going to change.
但多亏了我认识你母亲的方式，我再也不会担心了，因为这就是我，我永远不会改变。
I'll still be me forever.
我永远还是我。
So what I want to say is a big thank you, Josh, for everything.
所以我想说的是，非常感谢乔什，为我所做的一切。
By the way, listen to your songs and they are legend Wait for it, Derry.
顺便说一句，听听你的歌曲，它们都是传奇，等等，德里。
So that's awesome.
所以这太棒了。
Alec picked that one.
亚历克选了那个。
I didn't want it to seem like I was like, let's pick the one where they mentioned my music.
我不想让别人觉得我在想，让我们选一个他们提到我的音乐的吧。
Oh.
哦。
I am guilty.
我有罪。
Please equip me.
请装备我。
All sins off again.
一切罪孽再次消散。
New York City.
纽约市。
How we made your mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas.
《我们如何造就你的母亲》由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主持并担任监制。
The show was produced by me, Alec Lev.
该节目由我 Alec Lev 制作。
and our co-producer is Doug Matica.
我们的联合制片人是道格·马蒂卡。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point of Blue Studios.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Point of Blue Studios 的 Alex Reeves。
Artwork by John Morrow.
约翰·莫罗的艺术作品。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在 Apple 播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论该节目。
It really does help the show.
对节目确实有帮助。
Our theme song is NYC by our own Josh Radner, special thanks to Lowly Kennedy and Elliott Connards.
我们的主题曲是我们自己的 Josh Radner 创作的 NYC，特别感谢 Lowly Kennedy 和 Elliott Connards。
Visit howwemajormother.com to sign up for a sub-stack mailing list and for links to our social media.
请访问 howwemajormother.com 注册子堆栈邮件列表以及我们社交媒体的链接。
You can also click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
您还可以单击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音消息。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是节目的重要组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Riders' newsletters on Substack.
在 Substack 上订阅 Josh Riders 的时事通讯。
Read Craig Thomas' published prose at CraigThomasRider.com, and you can subscribe to my Dead Father Society also on Substack.
阅读 Craig Thomas 在 CraigThomasRider.com 上发表的散文，您也可以在 Substack 上订阅我的《已故父亲协会》。
You learn about how you make a difference.
您将了解如何发挥作用。
This shows ongoing campaign to raise money for a congenital heart disease research.
这表明为先天性心脏病研究筹集资金的活动正在进行中。
Check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
查看我们网站顶部的“Make a Difference”选项卡。
This episode was made possible by the support of backyard ventures, marketing provided by Tink Media.
这一集是在 Backyard Ventures 的支持和 Tink Media 的营销支持下得以实现的。
People will, in fact, dance.
事实上，人们会跳舞。
Craig, Josh, thank you for chatting with me, my friend.
克雷格、乔什，谢谢你们和我聊天，我的朋友。
Oh, man, this is a delight.
哦，伙计，这真是令人高兴。
This is a delight.
这是一件令人高兴的事。
If not one person listens, I'm still having a really good time, but I know it's due at 220 more times.
即使没有人听，我仍然玩得很开心，但我知道还有 220 次要到期。
Let's do it.
我们开始做吧。
At least.
至少。
Third times 13.
第三次 13.
Yeah, but it's a delight to spend time with you and Alec, and I'm excited to unpack this stuff.
是的，但很高兴与你和亚历克共度时光，我很高兴能打开这些东西。
And it feels honestly, it feels like psychologically healthy for me to do this, you know, it feels like, are you ready to go back to the Titanic?
老实说，这样做对我来说感觉心理健康，你知道，感觉就像是，你准备好回到泰坦尼克号了吗？
Yeah.
是的。
It's got a kind of quality of that, but I am, you know, let's do it.
它有这样的品质，但我，你知道，让我们这么做吧。
I've realized lately that the products I use every single morning genuinely affect how I feel for the rest of the day.
最近我意识到我每天早上使用的产品确实会影响我一天中剩下的时间的感觉。
If something feels heavy, greasy, overly make-up-y or complicated, I just stop reaching for it.
如果某样东西感觉很重、油腻、过度化妆或复杂，我就会停止接触它。
That's why I've been loving Primely Peer's new Sun Serum Tinted SPF.
这就是为什么我一直喜欢 Primely Peer 的新款防晒精华有色 SPF。
It gives mineral SPF 30 protection, and enough coverage to make my skin look even and healthy, but it still looks like my skin.
它提供 SPF 30 的矿物质保护，并有足够的遮盖力，让我的皮肤看起来均匀健康，但它看起来仍然像我的皮肤。
It has this really fresh, lived and glow, and their lip and cheek tint has become one of those products I keep throwing on throughout the day, because it makes me look instantly more awake and put together in like 10 seconds.
它真的很新鲜、充满活力、容光焕发，它们的唇部和脸颊色调已经成为我整天不断使用的产品之一，因为它让我看起来立刻更加清醒，并且在 10 秒钟内就完成了。
The whole vibe just feels very effortless, skinned first, clean girl beauty, products that enhance your skin.
整个氛围感觉非常轻松，首先是皮肤，干净的女孩美容，增强皮肤的产品。
If you've been wanting your routine to feel lighter, simpler, and more natural this summer, definitely check out Primely Peer's Sun Serum and Lip and Cheek Tints.
如果您希望今年夏天的日常护理变得更轻松、更简单、更自然，一定要看看 Primely Peer 的防晒精华和唇颊彩。
Amazon Music has everything you want to listen to.
亚马逊音乐拥有您想听的一切。
Music, podcasts, and now audio books.
音乐、播客，现在还有有声读物。
All in one app.
一切尽在一个应用程序中。
Amazon Music Unlimited.
亚马逊音乐无限。
Audio books included.
包括有声读物。